today on our show he directed the flames
i didn't write it you know dude this guy
that's who it is man
the writer of this week's episode of the
flash which i directed today on fat man
on batman
these illustrations are quite slimming
uh you know what i'm saying i think can
i get one too
we were looking at it last week and
going like this is unreal what a lie the
show begins alive two cartoons of us who
are who could get laid we can't no even
though we did get married so technically
we i i was gonna say i've seen the
office for ourselves i've seen the
i'm pretty sure they're yours good point
you hear that huh this guy's a writer
he's written stuff and he knows that
we've had sex so that means something
welcome to fat man i'm batman i'm kevin
smith mark bernard wearing my flash ring
today ladies and gentlemen because it is
flash damn my flash t-shirt you wore the
wrong flash t-shirt [ __ ] i wore the
correct flash tv yes
yes now this is a man without whom there
is no flash episode this week ladies and
gentlemen i would have got up to
vancouver and been like poor quack
because there have been nothing to do
had it not been written by this fine
gentleman right here zach stense what
you call a hollywood screenwriter give
him a single tell him what you've
written before look in that camera
authority the way a writer does it and
tell him
my name is zach stence and i am a
co-writer of agent cody banks nice the
first thor
and uh x-men first class as well as a
whole bunch of other things that never
got made news now television that's not
the same
i've written for terminator the sarah
connor chronicles
um fringe and uh now the flash and the
flash uh go to a or two shot or whatever
uh flashy did such a good job on is
there a camera flashy did such an
amazing job on i like spoilers he coming
back next season man i ain't burying the
lead i'm coming back next season they
said it on the internet i saw that on
the internet it wasn't on the internet
you can't take it never lies yeah warner
brothers set it to the internet so
done but yeah great people great show
and they order from great places for
lunch so is that what is good about it
i think i think i can't spoil this and i
can't speak for anybody until tees are
crossed eyes or dotted but i think when
i come back i might if i'm lucky get
another
zac extent script is that premature to
say sir
um i don't think i'm authorized to say
it back to me back to me for
authorization authorization
i'm authorized to say it i'll allow it i
said thank you the judge just weighed in
later
um one of the things i asked for when i
said uh you know because it wasn't like
here are my demands i wanted to go back
i begged them to go back to the show but
i said please the one thing i want is
like i want to keep that whole team
together they have alternating uh shoot
crews because they should shoot so many
episodes so it's not like the other crew
are wonderful people and i worked with
both because a piece of my episode the
tail end or tag with zoom and uh and the
meadows uh was shot on armin's set the
director of the previous episode so i
did get to work with that of the crew
but i spent a majority of the time with
the crew on the odd episode my episode
so i said if i come back when i come
back if you let me come back can i do it
with that crew again can i i kept saying
can't keep the home team together and it
looks like we'll be able to keep the
home team together even more so because
zach
probably is doing the script man and i'm
telling you right now go to go to a
three or whatever
or something or something i'm telling
you right you just watched that episode
like it's a special episode it goes in
pulls
like cleaves your chest and twain opens
it pulls the heart out shows you your
heart kisses it and that eats it in
front of you it's a heartbreaking
episode that all starts with the script
it was heartbreaking on the page as soon
as i hit the page where i turn and he
goes and it was a scene it was an act
break in the script but it wound up we
wound up going a little further in the
cut in terms of we married two scenes
together but the act break was him going
mom like oh and immediately i started
rolling
let's go back and i wish i could take
credit for that that one that that was
andrew kreisberg saying
the act out have been slightly different
and it's like dude this is the strongest
place to go out and as soon as i saw
that i was like yeah of course totally
and that's why you're the ep
but then to be fair then we changed it
it should have gone out on mom but our
act we felt like that's not it like
because you wanna once you see nora you
just wanna get into it so we took it one
step further and did the whole scene in
that that's right
and took it all the way to where she
touches her face and that was the like
if all we had to do was stay with them
for a minute and 45 seconds more and we
got to like rip their hearts out of the
chest the ought of the audience for that
moment and that was beautiful beautiful
moment let's let's go back to the
beginning like zach's done a bunch of
things we'll touch on those things but
first since we're flash is fresh in our
heads and whatnot let's talk about that
how did you get the job how did you wind
up writing the script um well
interestingly enough i was working with
uh with greg berlanti and andrew
kreisberg and sarah schechter the the
kind of amazing trio that that make that
amazing machine run and we're working on
a different project that i'm not really
allowed to talk about right now go to a
two shot but
go to us go to us we know what it is we
totally do we can't tell you not at all
back to zach now we were working on we
were working on a project together and
uh greg was a uh greg was becoming a new
dad which was uh which was amazing but
he was he was taking a little time off
and so we had this uh we had this gap in
the amount of time that we were working
on it and and andrew came up to me and
said well you know we don't want you to
be bored you want to write a flash
episode for us and you know
i was thinking it's i love the show it's
my middle son's absolute favorite show
and uh and it was a wonderful
opportunity to get my feet wet in tv
again and to learn kind of how these how
these people worked and kind of kind of
build up that rapport and so i
immediately said yes and
jumped into it and then found out lo and
behold it was going to be directed by
someone who i have been an admirer of
since i was a wannabe in my 20s
spike mic slackers and dykes oh my god
and uh cuts books reading reading about
the behind the scenes of the 90s indie
film scene in sundance and who was in
the hot tub with who
yeah i made it made him blush
and uh and you know what an amazing
opportunity and greg and andrew had a
specific idea because you know the show
is the show is pretty tightly serialized
like do you when they say
you're you want to write an episode are
you just like go nuts you have to work
within a structure yeah i worked within
i worked within the structure that they
gave me they gave me they were like
here's what we're thinking the big thing
is we know there's going to be a villain
that's gonna be a zombie version of a
season one villain come back to life and
then we had a little discussion over
well which one do we like and we'll and
we all kind of landed on girder because
uh you know we like you know it's he's a
big physical
presence and he had a connection with
iris which got us which got us the
opportunity to draw iris into the a
story really well
um so you know they had the big they had
some big ideas for it and how it would
go they we you know we sat in a room
together with them and with uh with the
with with todd and aaron the uh the the
other eps of the show
guys are fantastic yeah give me a two
shot i always talk about i always talk
about christmas because we had andrew on
the show in berlanti because it says
universe and stuff but the hellbengs man
like you know help one of the kids one
of the helping's kids gets his name on
the runaway dinosaur book and he did the
artwork for the coverage wonderful so
this dude like when you see the author
of the book when you look at the runaway
dinosaur
his kid drew the picture and his kid's
name's a book but the helpings are
wonderful like they are uh the glue that
keeps that show like the way people like
it really really strong strong talent
but for some reason whenever we talk
about the flash they always get left out
of the conversation but my process
honestly from from listening to your
description of how you did it it was it
was very similar and that it wasn't you
know oh here comes the feature writer
coming in to bigfoot everything and it's
like this is how we do it in movies it
wasn't like that at all it was it was me
going how can like you guys have built
this amazing show and this wonderful
machine how do i fit in how do i fit
into it and and that was that was the
pleasure of it and i'm sure it also
helped that you're you've got some tv
experience like it's not like your first
time in this yeah not my first rodeo not
my first rodeo and tv so you know you
understand when it's time to it's like
yeah i'm implementing someone else's
vision but here's all of the personal
stuff i've you know i have a close
relationship with my mom and you know
it's there was a lot of mom stuff in
there there was a lot of uh you know
there was a
you know when we first started talking
about it and they were saying and it's
burying the speed force and it's a
little bit like the prophets and deep
space nine the wormhole aliens and
things like that and then you know and
as we were talking we had the idea that
he was he was kind of going through the
kubler-ross stages of grief in terms of
being in the speed force so first he's
you know he's angry and he's in denial
and then he's depressed about it and
then he finally comes to a place of
acceptance by the end but as we were
talking about it and kind of talking
about him not coming to terms you know
that the deep thing was that he's never
come to terms with the death of his
mother and his own role in it and that
he understands that he's not going to
and that the the lesson the speed force
is trying to teach him is
dude if you're going to be a hero you're
going to have to learn how to live with
tragedy and and move on from it because
that's part of the that's part of the
job you signed up for so so as we were
talking about that i i said i can't get
a two-shot real quick i directed the
episode i don't even know what that was
about
are you serious that's beautiful man
that's really good he's a writer
back to him sorry no thank you um you
know and and as we're as we're talking i
i sort of blurted out because i love
kids books and i'm a parent myself i was
like oh this reminds me of the runaway
bunny
which which
you know was kind of a touchstone of it
and if if all of you are familiar or not
familiar with the children's classic by
margaret weiss brown it's uh it's about
a bunny who run who keeps saying that he
wants to run away from his mom and his
mom's saying wherever you are i'm going
to be there in a different in a
different form and
on one level it's a little stalkerish
but in another level
it's about unconditional love between a
parent and a child and
on a show that regularly brings me to
tears with exactly that subject it
seemed really great and then we realized
it's like you know how about instead of
the runaway bunny what if we do our own
version of it and that's you know and
you know thinking about every little boy
you know i was thinking about barry as a
little boy and thinking like what do
little boys love more than anything
dinosaurs so let's make the book about a
mommy dinosaur let's make the book about
a mommy dinosaur in her in her little
dinosaur and how that reflects on how
barry feels about his own mom the uh
which was beautiful and they did such a
great job with especially there's a as
we've seen now i can i don't have to be
like there's a scene the scene where she
reads to him where nora in the speed
force reads him the book it's beautiful
you really like touching emotional stuff
um the scene itself is beautiful the
contents of the book really beautiful
there the book story though like this is
a weird background book story and this
is a telling story about somebody who
doesn't have a boy i got a daughter so
originally it was runaway bunny because
we named this the episode was named
after the book but getting clearing
runaway bunny
you gotta clear it becomes a thing and
stuff and rather than go through the
rigmarole we're just like look make
something up this is tv so i said ooh
call it
you know i was staying close to bunny
cause i was like call it run bunny run
you know run berry run is the thing of
the show and uh they when i got the
draft of the script and it was dinosaur
i was like dinosaur i was like why
dinosaur and there was a line at one
point in the scriptures like boys and
their dinosaurs i was like oh
because i wasn't a traditional boy
growing up so i like dinosaurs were in
my thing but i had a daughter and she
was elephants more so than dinosaurs and
it's not like girls can't be into
dinosaurs lots more but that is a very
not imposed gender role yeah so
exactly but it is a very like it was a
telling sign that my kid was not a
dinosaur person that i read that script
going dinosaur
who likes dinosaurs i was like i don't
know i'm a man i don't like dinosaurs
and it's beautiful man it's actually
really sweet particularly when he gets
to
like he's reading one he starts reading
the book aloud to her and from memory
and that's like that's when it starts
gushing it's really sweet moment yeah oh
and i mean i mean thinking about the
books that your parents read you and the
books that you read your kids and things
like that it's it's there are ones that
my mom read to me that i can recite by
heart that i can recite by heart and
those are those are some of the most
cherished memories that you that you
carry with you as an adult or are those
those little moments of bonding with you
or with your parents and feeling so open
and vulnerable i know that i know there
was a little bit of fear i don't know
where it came from probably the network
or something like that that it's like
well doesn't barry seem like a little
like a little kid or you know like like
doesn't he you know we don't want him to
regress too much but it's like when you
have grant like someone who's willing to
be emotionally open and vulnerable in a
way that you you never see in a
superhero story
it's it's you know he he can be that but
then stand up and i'm gonna go fight the
bad guy now that's that's what makes
that's to me where where the flash lives
as a show and what it's bringing to the
table that none of those other shows
that none of those other shows or movies
for that matter are yeah i remember as a
kid growing up in new york we would
always go to the museum of natural
history on school trips did you ever go
from jersey no no no wouldn't cross
state lines
the big city that's scary but it was
always like the thing was you go there
you see the dinosaurs i had the
skeletons of everything and i remember
asking a teacher like when i got older
and started to bring my kids like how
come kids like dinosaurs so much
and she said because it's the first
thing that a kid sees that's bigger than
their parents
ah like it is it is literally the first
thing that is towering over the people
who tower over them like it is this
thing that's larger that's interesting
that's the world they've ever seen
before
and i think that you know
granted i'm still a little raw on the
episode so i haven't gotten to digest it
yet but the idea that the speed force is
bigger than barry
you know and that it all kind of
dovetails in in the thing like
responsibility and earning your place in
the world and being okay with being a
part of something that's bigger than you
are all right let's ask the writer is
that what you were thinking when you
wrote that
not consciously but
i'm going with that i'm going with that
i like that right like
yeah that's what i'm doing
yeah it's that i i think that's thematic
i think that's thematically really dead
on because it's it is barry coming up
against you know i mean barry and the
speed force it's barry coming up against
limits it's barry coming coming up again
you know it's it and
as we were breaking it and we were
talking about the different stages that
he was going through and i remember
talking to greg and andrew and at one
point uh you know they were like well
you know should he be angry at at any
point and what should it be and it's you
know saying well in a way this is the
scene you know this is the episode where
he gets to talk to god yes and don't you
always want the scene where captain kirk
tells god to go [ __ ] himself yes um what
does god need with the stars exactly
it's like and
you know
the speed force has put barry through a
lot of awful stuff and you kind of want
barry to call the speed force on that
and say this is effed up what you guys
are doing to yeah i've busted my ass
i've killed myself
literally killed myself trying to trying
to make use of this and now you're
telling me i'm not worthy because i'm
rejecting my gift well you know screw
you guys yeah it is it's a real that's
what i was trying to like dance around
it before they start put the preview
together and stuff like that and the
pictures but it started getting online
but you know people like what's the
episode about i'm like well
barry meets his maker
you know and people were like ah and
then like literally that's kind of what
it is it can't like it's weird as i
watched the whole episode i'm like this
would totally play for like a real
christian crowd because it is it's very
meeting god more or less it's just the
speed force did you get the uh the you
know the the scene with joe when he's
explaining the speed force that's very
that that's very loosely paraphrased
from a sandman uh from a sandman
commonwealth no what tell which one holy
crap the one where he's saying you know
when the first elementary particle
sprung into being and when the last we
called it the matrix moment while we
were shooting we're like once we get
jesse into the chair we can do our
architect matrix moment or our morpheus
moment where he's just like do you know
what the matrix is new in the in this in
the i know you're a sandman fan and in
the
big run of the sandman the first episo
the first issue where they gave death
her own issue her own issue
she gives this great monologue about
like death being the first thing and the
one who's gonna you know to turn out the
lights on the universe when it's you
know and put the chairs on the tables
and and lock the door behind her when
she when she leaves at the end of the
universe and i always thought that was
that was so profound with a guy who
wouldn't die where she keeps meeting
that guy throughout his life
sure if it was the same one but it was
it was in that run it was in that room
she meets we dream in the park and
that's where we meet death for the first
time right and you're like oh cool
chicken
and then you're like it's death what an
ingenious but yeah joe is the joe as the
speed forces uh joe is the speed force's
speech was was i shall we say inspired
by that by that sandman awesome is that
to know that like even it's a comic book
show and comic books
inspired even like moments within it now
tell them as a writer because most some
cats that don't do this that's okay you
know what i'm saying some cats are like
what you took that from sandman now he's
inspired by it man he paraphrased like
writers all artists crib and steal from
people in real life other movies they
see something makes you feel a certain
way you're like i'm gonna do my version
of that and stuff so that was you going
like oh i'll always like that speech let
me do a version of that speech no it's
funny i'm developing uh um
as i'm working on the flash i'm also
developing a show of my own for uh for
i i can't say free form formerly abc
family and it's a kind of genre show and
you know big genre elements and i
remember talking to another writer about
it and saying like i think we need to
prince zuko and like
you know and there are other people in
the room and you know half the people
are like what are you talking about and
then anyone who watched avatar the last
airbender was like oh yeah we want the
the seeming villain who who's actually a
tortured soul and who ends up having a
you know heel face turn at the end and
you know like
it's it's
you go you know i mean we in the flash
writers room we talk about buffy all the
time you know really it's a great i mean
it's it's a reference point but as a
show that did genre and did in you know
kind of pioneered the whole structure of
like the big bad for the season and
things like that a lot of the terms that
genre tv uses were kind of pioneered by
by those those first few seasons of
buffy yeah like we're all a synthesis
right like we're all like sort of making
our way through the world and we just
take and we absorb and at some point we
kind of just output like hey that's a
that's a thing i remember loving when i
was eight like i want to talk about this
i want to talk about that i read this
book once this was awesome yeah think
about the moment with his he's talking
about his relationship with his mother
all the books that his him and his mom
ever read together led to that
sequence which is it's an indelible
memory if you watch that show like if i
was a guy just watching this show i had
nothing to do with it even i'd be like
one of my favorite scenes in the world
was when he sat there and read with his
mother yeah it's like beautiful you know
i i think writing is always going to be
good when it comes from a real and
personal place in people and that's
that's it drives me freaking nuts when
people talk about comic book movies and
comic book shows is somehow oh it's just
people in capes punching each other or
what have you and and
and there's so many ways of making it
personal of investing it there's like
there's a scene in x-men first class
that's that's that's right out of like
oh this is how it felt to be in college
and finally meet people who you felt
like understood you for for the first
time in your life it's like i don't know
what it's like to be a mutant but i know
what it's like to meet people for the
first time in my life who who i feel
understand me and those are the kinds of
personal access points that i think all
of us as storytellers put in put in our
work at least you know i mean like thor
is very much about like two brothers
fighting for the love of a father like
everything else whatever else is
happening there is these two kids one of
which then finds out he's adopted and
doesn't feel like he's worth the same
amount of love maybe but it's very much
about fathers and sons and and dueling
for emotion and for affection no
absolutely and
what's that you buy that
oh that's that's that's exactly what
that's that's what we're doing good job
that's what we always talked about is is
it's like oh we got freaking kenneth
branagh it's like this is a
shakespearean family drama about you
know a king and two princes walk us
through that so was that the first agent
cody banks was the first yeah that was
like
no we got brought in by a producer who's
a dear friend of ours to uh to um
rewrite a script that needed a lot of
love and a lot of tlc and this is you
and ashley miller yeah this was me and
uh and uh ashley edward miller so we
went in and did that and then we got
rewritten and turned by the the guys who
are now doing uh the uh the o.j simpson
show real scott and larry scott and
larry you know these you know so who got
rewritten by like oscar caliber writers
scott and like the guys scott
alexander's
the guys that did the people vs larry
flint yeah so they did that oj thing
yeah yeah yeah and they did the o.j i
know i'm late but now i feel like i
should watch them you should do last
year it's amazing
yeah they're they're
amazing watch this so those dudes
i'm
pretty
rewrote you on asian coding and we all
shared credit together it was very
amicable i'm friends with them on
facebook now
that has always happened is that a thing
for like if how many times have you ever
been rewritten or had to share
co-writing credit in a place where it
wasn't somebody you invited in with you
every single time what's it feel like as
a writer because i'm a writer if that
happens to me i'd be like ah how does it
what is it what how do you deal i mean
you kind of view your you have to be
philosophical about it you have to take
a step back and say
you know what i am one of
several hundred people who contributed
to this
and i can see stuff up there that's me i
can see stuff up there that's the writer
who came before me i can see stuff up
there that's the writer who came came
after me and the credit will be what it
will be
sometimes you know thor ended you know
we all like fought each other in
arbitration it it it ended with uh what
we all thought was a pretty fair credit
and we became good friends with the late
don payne who uh who'd rewritten us on
thor
um
and uh
the x-men first-class process i was not
as amicable but uh but uh we ended up
with a credit we were really happy with
and you know they're they're like huge
sections of that movie that it's like oh
yeah they just shot shot what we wrote
there and then there are other sections
that are like
i don't remember any of that
why did they kill a black guy
dude
i did i did a panel in washington dc
where i had to defend that decision
which by the way you know i fought
strenuously against
sitting next to tonahashi coats
you know who had just written an article
for the new york times about taking his
son to see x-men first class and how
disappointed they were by the black guy
dying halfway through so like literally
the preeminent you know black
male non-fiction writer in america
standing next to me i'm like
giving you something you know you know
he was so nice he's he's the nicest guy
but but you know and we we went out with
you know
later with neil drumming you're a friend
and got incredibly drunk but uh as you
do with neil drummond as as one as one
does but yeah i mean i mean you know but
honestly if your name is on it you need
to own it whether you were in favor of
the decision or whether whether you
weren't it's like yeah you know that
happened that was a decision that was
made it went my name is on it and i
cashed the check
all right take us through thor how do
you get the job like you have to
audition you go into a room and be like
here's my idea for the story or like
this is the story we went ash and i went
on one of those general writers meetings
that you go on all the time i don't know
what that is
generally invites me to [ __ ] so what is
that
um you know where studios want to get to
know new writers and want to get to know
you and kind of you know it's it's butt
sniffing essentially it's dog's butt
sniffing and seeing if seeing if they
think your butt smells good or not
um we had one of those meetings and it
was great we pitched a bun you know it's
like here's some different marvel
properties we should do stuff with and
it's like within that world uh it's like
feige so he's in the room yeah i mean
this was way back at the this was like
2009 you know like it was way back
early phase one uh you know craig kyle
people like people like that really good
really good people so we we had a great
meeting and it was like oh that was
great we pitched i think we pitched
power pack
really yeah and then
you know we're hanging low oh god this
was before that because this was before
the writers strike yeah it was that far
back so so the writer strike happened i
remember like it was late 2008 ash and i
were sitting in our in our office at the
terminator writer's room looking weirdly
enough looking at a picture of treat
williams and everwood on the wall greg
berlanti show very blind um just showing
how these things are connected and and i
remember turning to ash and saying
remember that meeting we had with marvel
a year ago
we're never going to hear from them
again
literally the next day they called and
said
you guys know anything about thor
i will confess i didn't know a lot about
thor ash knew thor backwards and
forwards so of course of course we do we
know you know but but ash because you
know it's like he can talk beta ray bill
for for 20 minutes
um
you know so they called us in
we were very lucky and that we were in
the right place in the right time they
needed at that point they were rushing a
schedule they were rushing a schedule um
thor came out in 2011. originally it was
supposed to be a 2010 movie they had a
script that didn't work
they were going in a completely
different direction because before like
mark produceevich had done a really good
script of thor but it was very it was
all viking era it was all off in its own
world mythological story and now that
they had phase one they were like okay
this needs to half of it needs to be on
earth and it needs to start setting up
the fact that he's gonna be in the
avengers and we have the vague idea that
loki is a good villain and and is going
to be a is going to be a big villain
late later on
um
the fact that we knew comic books was
great what was even more important is
because we were tv guys they knew we
were fast
um so they they brought us in they had
us meet with ken who is already the
who's already the director
um we kind of gave they said here's our
idea for the movie we're like okay well
we like these parts there's no third act
and you need to turn here and there's no
force of opposition the entire time
these on earth here are solves for that
they're like that sounds pretty good
contract came really quickly and then i
think we had three weeks to write the
first draft we were like it was like a
tv schedule we're we're turning out and
you're not rewriting this is from a page
one this is a page this was a page one
based you know based very loosely on
story beats that they gave us we found
out also kind of like what you did in
flashes
it was a lot like that there were beats
that they had and beats that they didn't
have and we were kind of working them
together you know at one point it was
like okay we want shield to be in there
and they're like we can't have shields
as the bad guys no not the bad guys just
the people opposing thor they'll be the
good guys by the end trust us
um and then they're like well you can
have shield but sam jackson's holding us
up in negotiations so we don't know if
he can have nick fury and we're like
well how about that clark gregg guy from
the first iron man he was great and he
popped can we have coulson and they're
like
oh him yeah are you [ __ ] me so you
guys are probably the ones that start
them going hey let's thread coulson
throughout all of these
no they ended up giving him a bigger
role in iron man 2 because they liked
how he was popping and how he was like
how he was popping in thor clark greg
actually sent us a t-shirt
sent us t-shirts as a thank you for you
like gold bullion freaking t-shirt i'm
holding up for something higher man
part of that world clark keep getting
the centerpiece of the avengers the
whole reason they go to battle on the
third act show
you want to know who owes us and hasn't
said anything was you know like
part way through there was like you know
and then the shield sniper takes aim and
then it's like we identify barton and
they're they're like
oh but if we get hawkeye we'll have to
get a real actor and then they realize
it's like oh we can just shoot the a
side and then when we cast when we cast
for the avengers we'll just go back and
shoot a thing really really
that was planned yeah and then that's so
so jeremy renner you're welcome
um all right take us through
um
first class how does that happen how do
you get that job who do you have to meet
with um first class we met with an
awesome executive at fox we had another
general meeting and it was it was with
drew crevello this really smart guy um
he ended up at warner's warner later but
he's he's also kind of the secret father
of deadpool like he was the one who was
like you know while we were working on
x-men he was bringing me into his office
and he was showing me this this cut
scene from a dc game and saying like
superhero stuff has never been directed
this well it's like i think the guy who
directed this was
tim miller
he he he was the one who got rhett and
paul um uh recent wernuck writing
deadpool and he was the guy who said i
think tim miller is the next great
director and like god got him on he was
that guy he was absolutely right that's
him miller kid he's got a future yeah
exactly so he so so drew brought us in
we had a great general he's like i love
you guys i want to find something for
you and we walked out of it going yeah
we'll never hear from him again
and then like
two weeks later it was okay we want you
to come in and we want you to read a
script you have to stay in the office
and read it and then we want you to
react to it and then we want you to
leave and it was a draft that they had
of x-men first class that was not
working
and they said here's the deal
we've already tom rothman then head of
the studio has set a release date
we don't have a director we know who we
want to direct we want matthew vaughn to
direct um and if we can't get him we
want someone else really good and we
know we're not going to get a director
of that caliber with this script you
guys have three weeks to turn this into
a script that works go um brian singer
was then a producer on it we met with
brian a couple of times he had some you
know he had actually come up with the
kind of the bones of the idea for you
know the like cuban missile crisis and
uh and uh um sebastian shaw's the bad
guy and things like that so we met with
him um he helped us break story a little
bit but then it was off to the races and
that was another that was another
three-week special so we we ended up
working on that and i've never that was
like tv because you know having i you
know how how big movies work
i've seen a few and they seem very
expensive
but i mean a 150 million dollar movie
that a year before your release date you
do not have a script and do not have a
director is uh it's not unprecedented
but it's almost unprecedented so they
were dangerous
it's incredibly dangerous so we like to
say we taught them all the wrong lessons
that you can do that you can throw it
together at the last second it'll
actually turn out pretty well it's a
good movie man this is like a strong
story it's a fun script i really like it
i really like it a lot yeah yeah yeah
that movie plays and it shouldn't cause
thor but it works that movie works by
the time it like the i love the fact
that it's asgard and earth i love the
relationships that they set up like i
like that movie man yeah first class is
also just a really good talk about we
shouldn't talk about first class yeah
first class is a really good movie both
of those movies set the table for what's
going to come i mean coulson is a big
part of it you know hawkeye is
introduced there you get all of those
like the the gen 1 versions of the x-men
without that stuff you don't have the
other four movies that they're spinning
out of that yeah no i i could work it
was really incredible
it was really pretty we did on the on
both of those yeah um so that led you to
eventually the job that you're doing
over with berlanti and at warner
brothers that we won't talk about but
eventually led to flash as well yes that
led there there's a there's a
not a straight line but at least uh you
know you the the maze that they give you
like when you're at the kids restaurant
with the crayons like you can you can
draw on the crayon and get from from
there to there you got dolly to big boy
did you
sounds like
the uh all right let's talk about the
flash episode again when you
so you wrote the episode eventually you
have to see the episode
be directed and this was one where
generally when you look at things like
you said before you're like oh we did
that someone else did that someone else
did that but this is you all the way
through right like there's no nobody
came in after you yeah i mean i mean
you know there were
as as you know from seeing it the the
script gets increasingly rainbow colored
is not too much though on our draft from
what i understood like production they
were like this is the fewest drafts
we've ever seen because that script from
draft one was the money right away you
were like there's really nothing to do
except yeah if anything i think i did
like two or three rewrites and then i
think uh the helbings and uh and andrew
did their own did their own like uh
yeah
added their showrunner special sauce um
and uh you know and you know i should be
so lucky is to have writers that good uh
that that good doing that it's like
truly you've got people like oh we do
this every week so let's just do a flash
pass on it real quick and it makes it
look even better you're like oh my lord
all right so when the script is done it
goes off to get made and stuff you're
off working on the other thing again
then eventually they're like hey here's
a cut of it you can watch it yeah they
got me a cut a couple weeks ago and i
was i i was really happy and i it's it's
really fun because my kids are really
interested in how production works and
so it was a lock cut but it was it was
without the uh the final vfx so it was
really fun seeing like the anime you
know it's like and then barry is in the
speed force and it's like
it says barry vfx
isn't it amazing though considering
you're watching green screen and
sometimes you're watching a scene that
literally has those words on the screen
like vfx tbd or whatever
as you watch it you can see through it
because their performances are so strong
and also that was a strong script yeah
story and character my first tv show was
the syndicated action hour where like
the final special effects were not much
better
that we did so i'm very experienced in
using my imagination it's like okay i
can squint and imagine the good version
of this except the thing about the flash
is they give you the good version week
after week and what they also do too is
like uh hats off to the post-production
crew on that show armin and his folks
like do the final special effects but
even when you're cutting the episode
together they have people in the office
that could do temp effects so anytime he
was flat you know zooping and leaving
they were able to throw lightning on to
even a temp cut that you're looking at
which
goes a long way toward like oh my lord
like honestly the temp special effects
in the first loose cut of flash probably
better than the final special effects in
dogma in the future
you know granted there's 1999 but it's
like you could do a lot more now but
like they looked really presentable so
much so that i'm like i'll live with
that armin could like vfx the hell out
of your [ __ ] demon yeah you ain't
kidding norman could have went back in
time and gave us a really good looking
poop monster you know the uh you know
the um the king shark episode
our good friends uh ben and derek wrote
it and uh
i know the guys yeah and they're now
they're now uh they're now on the coeps
on the show how does that happen so what
happens you write an episode and like
come be on the show yes when is it right
i'm an ep what is the difference and
when does that happen you know it's it's
i've never been an ep um
you know it's it's not like getting
jumped into the gang but it's it's uh
why not yeah it's gonna be amazing if
like she just
you know all of those
you know a lot of people don't know like
those those terms you know like
supervising producer co-ep ep those are
those are rank terms it's like it's like
captain colonel
major
general two-star gym
general through star general and the and
ep is like the the you salute the ep
yeah commander-in-chief for the pacific
fleet when you get a [ __ ] when you go
from a writer to what is the next thing
uh writer to story editor and then
executive story editor and then
co-producer then producer supervising
producer co-ep ep and that's all one
different all different names for writer
yeah all of those people are writers
except some of the eps don't write that
that gets complicated but all of them
are but their rank structures and
they're how much everyone's getting paid
in in regards to everything so for derek
and ben those guys have been working in
tv for about a decade now and they
started as baby writers on a tv show and
then they slowly worked their way up
they were they were just on beauty and
the beast
they are friends andrew kreisberg song
is all this time
no the tv show on the cw
there was a meeting they did another one
yeah yeah yeah that's right but uh but
derek and ben no ron turnellman though
i thought it was the old not the good
one how old are these yes as old as the
hills uh but andrew kreisberg had worked
with both of those guys on warehouse 13
a thousand years ago and so now they
have me back up hey we're now co-ep
level we'd like to do a freelance great
come on in write us a king shark and
then for next season they got so it was
an audition piece to say it was an
audition piece for for staffing and then
that means and they hear you come in
knock that baby out of the park if they
want to and i'm actually um
i'm allowed to say this now i'm coming
in part-time as a consulting producer
which is kind of outside of the rank
structure but i'm going to write a few
episodes maybe maybe even for my my new
best friend here he's definitely going
to do that
and
you know mainly it's you know excuse to
hang out with amazing creative people
and uh eat snacks and work on a show
that like admittedly we like i love you
know what i'm saying like it's a fun
show to watch as a writer can you how is
it to watch other things can you just be
like i'm gonna turn that part off and
just consume and enjoy or is there a
party that's like i would change that i
wouldn't have done that i wouldn't have
done that you know when i watch
something for the first time i always
try and turn off my writer turn off the
writer brain and turn on the fan brain
and frankly flash makes it really easy
because it it tickles so many of my fan
fanboy sweet spots that's you know it's
it's
you go in you go in to that writer's
room and you see on the board heart
humor spectacle and
that's that's
that's literally up on that is literally
written on the right on the on the on
the driver
blazing in my heart heart humor and
spectacle and in my brain yeah i think
that's andrew i think that's andrew's uh
andrew
for anything that almost anything any
movie should really be hard humor and
spectacle um i i like dartmouth i dinner
with andre
hearts humor spy girl two
i'll tell you this though like
doing directing that show hands down i'm
not just saying it like in a positive
way like hey we should be nice and say
this one of the best experiences of my
career and not just my life dude
honestly like probably a top five
experience of my career probably top ten
experience in my life if you watch the
behind-the-scenes footage like that they
put up recently
like i'm beaming i'm having like the
time of my life and that's because you
gave me a great script to work with dude
like everyone loves this episode like
honestly i spent the day on twitter
like reading a bunch of people who are
like you're amazing they haven't even
seen the episode yet but they've seen
all the behind the scenes and the
trailers and stuff and i'm getting a lot
of props and stuff but it wouldn't
happen without me without you you gave
me a [ __ ] gift dude i could walk in
and i said it in some of the interviews
that i was doing the other day like i
was worried going into i was like i want
to do this but like i don't know how to
direct like episodic that's been up for
two for two seasons but when i got there
and i opened that script it was like
being at a poker table and being dealt a
royal flush you look at your cards and
you're like oh my lord like i'm gonna
run the table right now and that's
because you gave me something wonderful
to work with well thank you and you did
an amazing job directing and i'm gonna
say it was easy and i'm not saying that
to brag um or to say it was easy because
i was a good writer it was easy because
they created such wonderful characters
who are you know when you're sitting
there you know on final draft and it's
like what's joe gonna say it's like you
know who joe what joe is gonna say
because they've written him so well and
because jesse martin is gonna deliver
that line that's like i wish you were my
daddies
oh my god why aren't you my dad joe you
think that's you think it's that way
watching the show just be on set with
jesse while he delivers a line and when
he's not even doing lines from the show
like there was one point where he's he's
gary's is a wonderful guy he's got a
great voice great personality and energy
on set and also you know i'm a big rent
fan so yeah he was on set at one point
and like chit chat and stuff i walked
over
and i went like i was going to go talk
to him about like something about the
show but i walked over i leaned over i
was like live in my house which is like
that song
and he broke up man he's such a sweet
guy like yeah i could if you think you
want to be your father when you watch
the show hang out with him for five
minutes oh man like you want to be your
father your best friend everything's
good actor good yeah but they're i mean
you're right you got their voices
because those like not only is the
writing so amazing on the show but
you've got actors like you get to
look at what's gone before watch their
performance and kind of write to the
voice exactly
it's like big blonde guy yeah like you
don't know what it's gonna be
yeah it could have been one of eight big
you know i i i was there you know it's
like is that alex skarsgard yeah is that
the sons of anarchy guy um was there a
chance that it might have been alexander
skarsgard yeah those are the other two
those are the other two main candidates
were charlie hunnam and skarsgard but
i just that just snapped my breath i
think gemsdale's wonderful i love those
guys but but i think hemsworth was the
right choice just because of that
just that freaking charm that that that
freaking charm that he brought yeah you
know i mean i remember seeing him in the
beginning of star trek i'm like who is
that guy that's right he's a movie star
and he has like three minutes in the
movie yeah and he made such an impact
that was that's right i forgot about it
yeah it's a good choice
opening of of jj star trek like always
brings my wife and i both
are naming the baby
it's tiberius god that's a horrible name
that's so damn good like that honestly
you can see why for the first five
minutes of star trek alone you can see
why the game star wars
like first opening minute five minutes
of star trek so strong you're in space
it's like yeah we get it but it's also
it's about the human experience in the
midst of like giant warships firing upon
one another there's a birth of a kid and
a guy who's trying to talk to his wife
as she's going through it yeah no it's
great stuff um all right you guys
anything i got nothing we should let him
go he's gotta go uh he's gotta he's
gonna go home and watch the episodes
see how badly see how badly kevin [ __ ]
it up
i totally dropped the ball on this one
man i had a good script and i [ __ ] it
that's that's what they told me on the
flesh that's why they're invited and
that's why they're inviting him back
um again man i can't thank you enough
dude you you gave me look at this hugs
this man like you gave me credibility
dude in a place where
you know i make weird movies now where i
dress up like a sausage and [ __ ] so i
can take all the credibility
that i can get and the fact of the
matter is you gave me like great words
to work with and and because of that we
turned in what i feel is pretty
wonderful so thank you thank you i can't
wait for all of you to see it yes there
it is folks uh thanks for all thanks
i was going all over uh thanks for being
hanging out with us here in the fat
games that big thanks to zach's sense
not just for writing the episode but for
and for all the scripts that he wrote
but also for coming in and talking
tonight man thank you so much
good man charlie brown uh there it is
folks uh for fat man i'm batman i'm
kevin smith i'm mark bernard and this is
zach's tense uh tune in with us next
week us not him he's going right he's
got a job
he's got things to do you're hurt
he's got a script to write scripts he's
working on uh same fat time for us same
fat channel smilecast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith flash out